cher sportif musclé ou retraités le
temps des j'ai raccroché les crampons c
est terminé ou d'un côté la réforme des
retraites qui continue de faire parler
entre les opposants qui battent le pavé
les échanges musclés à l'assemblée de
l'autre les sportifs de haut niveau un
secteur ni entendu ni écoutés loin du
cliché des neymar aime bape et surpayés
la profession est souvent précarisés 4
sur 10 gagnerait à moins de 500 euros
par mois selon un rapport ministériel de
2015 préjugés mis de côté les sportifs
de haut niveau n'ont ni régime spécial
ni aide particulière h pivot régimes
spéciaux 49,3 à débat ou pas débat
quelle retraite pour les athlètes on en
parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouveau
numéro de l'autre match spécial retraite
alors que la réforme du gouvernement
poursuit son parcours législatif
quelle retraite pour les sportifs de
haut niveau on n'entend pas forcément
parlé et nous on va en parler sur ce
plateau avec nos invités sandra ribeiro
homo vous êtes une persiste franco
portugaise avait remporté plusieurs fois
les championnats de france les
championnats du portugal
vous allez participer également aux jeux
olympiques de pékin en 2008 et puis vous
êtes la présidente de perf est une
entreprise qui accompagnent les sportifs
de haut niveau pendant leur carrière
mais aussi surtout après leur carrière
bonjour merci d'être avec bonjour merci
pour l'invitation à vos côtés pierre
rondeau économiste du sport bonjour vous
êtes également chroniqueur rmc bfm tv
si vous êtes l'auteur d'une étude sur la
retraite des sportifs de haut niveau
pour la fondation jean jaurès avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet une stat
importante elle date de 2015 un rapport
ministériel à l'époque le secrétaire
d'état s'était thierry braillard cette
stat c'est celle ci quatre sportifs de
haut niveau sur 10 gagnerait moins de
500 euros par mois
pierre rondeau les sportifs de haut
niveau ne mènent donc pas tous grand
train à l'instar des neymar ou les
hommes d'affairé banon mais justement
parce que là on parle des footballeurs
professionnels et peuvent pas pas
n'importe lesquels les grands
footballeurs les très connus qui gagnent
très bien leur vie
voilà c'est vrai que neymar c'est 3,06
millions d'euros par mois on va pas se
plaindre on va pas se préoccuper de la
situation mais effectivement le sport ce
n'est pas que le football le sport c'est
d'athlétisme cet judo avec la natation
c'est le hand c'est de voler le football
et richissime et le football génère
beaucoup d'argent donc génère beaucoup
de redistribution pour les footballeurs
les principaux sportif et donc leur
rémunération
mais à côté tous les sportifs et
l'immense majorité des sportifs de haut
niveau qui participent aux jeux
olympiques et participe à des
championnats du monde gagne très mal
leurs vies ne sont absolument pas à
compagnies ne sont pas aidés ne sont pas
soutenues et résultats que vous l'avez
dit 4 sur 10 gagnent moins de 500 euros
par mois
quelle est votre situation à vous en
tant que père schiste est ce que vous
êtes dans cette même situation et
pensez vous déjà retraite forcément là
je parle je parle pas à la présidente de
société je parle à la perchiste moment
en tant que persiste je dirais que j'ai
eu un peu de chance puisque je jouais
sur double tableau donc j'étais à
sportive franco portugaise donc j'ai pu
via ma fédération des clubs ou des
partenaires sponsors vivre de ma passion
mais je sais que beaucoup de mes
collègues sportives aujourd'hui ramé ont
du mal à finir les fins de mois puisque
sans partenaire 100 entreprises
partenaires sans sponsor sens si on ne
travaille pas c'est difficile de mener
ce qu'on appelle ce double projet
justement
lapret carrière vous y pensiez déjà les
sportifs entre ce qu'ils ont pas est ce
qu'ils pensent à la retraite est ce
qu'il parle de la réforme des retraites
actuelles aujourd'hui on en parle mais
peut-être pas suffisamment puisque on va
parler de la retraite avec les sportifs
surtout sur le côté information
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu fais
comme études qu'est-ce que tu prévois de
faire demain mais la retraite je pense
que c'est encore très loin puisqu'il ya
très peu de choses qui sont mis en place
très peu de sensibilisation auprès
auprès des sportifs donc faut réveiller
toute une culture changer les mentalités
pour que pour que les sportifs se sont
encore plus concernés sur cette question
des retraites puisque après justement un
réveil là vous parlez de réveil avec la
réforme du gouvernement
avec un régime universel il n'y a pas de
régime spécial pour les sportifs est ce
que la seule mesure de tout remettre à
plaindre non mais justement comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une comme il n'ya pas
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui un régime
spécial pour les sportifs de haut niveau
le fait qu'on passe un régime universel
avec la réforme des retraites ne va rien
changer à leur quotidien
il y en avait pas avant et n'aura pas
après donc ils n'ont pas amélioré
y'a pas à voir une amélioration leur
situation grâce ce régime universel dans
la mesure il était déjà intégré un
régime universel le régime des cadres en
l'occurrence pour les sportifs et se
précise salariés ce serait con il faut
faire le distinguo entre les
footballeurs les rugbymans les
handballeurs qui sont dépendants d'un
club et qui sont à ce titre la salariée
et payent des cotisations retraite et
donc petit à petit cotisent pour cette
retraite future et des athlètes comme
les écoles justement en athlétisme en
judo wire qui sont leur propre chef
d'entreprise en tennis aussi par exemple
qui sont leur propre chef d'entreprise
qui doivent gérer à la fois un projet
sportif et un projet économique mais qui
doivent gérer la même chose cette chose
sur le sur les deux tableaux l'aspect
économique l'aspect sportif est donc
cette réforme je répète ne va rien
changer puisque les rapa n'y avait pas
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas après deux
régimes spécifiques pour évoquer pour
les sportifs qu'est-ce que vous sandra
vous attendez du gouvernement en terme
de retraites pour pour les sportifs
comment est-ce que vous jugez cette
réforme des retraites pour les sportifs
c'est vrai qu'avec 2
dernier secrétaire d'état thierry
braillard il y avait eu une première
avancée pour mettre en place un
dispositif de retraite pour les sportifs
de haut niveau
mais aujourd'hui ce dispositif qui
concerne peut-être une 500 sportifs en
tout donc ce qui est très peu concernant
le nombre de sportifs qui aujourd'hui se
retrouve sur la touche et dont il aurait
besoin de cette aide pour avancer donc
je pense qu'il faudrait réfléchir sur un
dispositif vraiment plus spécifique
puisque le monde du sport c'est une
spécificité donc peut-être tenté de
rentrer de rentrer dans sa pour pouvoir
mieux accompagner les sportifs de haut
niveau est considérée l'espoir un peu
amateur comme vous l'avez si bien dit
l'athétisme ou d'autres sports comme un
métier je pense que c'est vraiment le
problème des le moment considéra que
être sportif de haut niveau est un
métier balle qui tournera autour pourra
peut-être évolué et changé
je pense que c'est là où il ya un
problème de culture en france c'est
qu'on a trop tendance à considérer le
sport le football le tennis ou d'autres
sports comme un loisir et non pas comme
un métier à part entière et à ce titre
là on n'aurait pas on n'aurait pas après
les sportifs n'aurait pas se plaindre ou
a appelé à une amélioration de leur
situation dans la mesure où il s'amuse
on parle de jeu pour le sport on parle
de loisirs de pratique de loisirs
vraiment d'amusement et de métier
contraignant de pénibilité pour le
travail et ont donc il serait logique
d'accorder des aides et des soutiens
pour les travailleurs est illogique de
faire de même pour les sportifs puisque
il s'amuse
or je pense qu'en france on a un très
gros problème de culture à ce niveau là
le sport de haut niveau c'est un métier
à part entière avec une pénibilité avec
une rigueur de vie avec des contraintes
assez nombreuses et il faut à ce titre
là les aider les soutenir et la dernière
chose que je rajouterai aussi à ce
niveau là c'est de rappeler tout de même
que les français sont adore regarder des
compétitions sportives adore regarder
des jo adore regarder des coupes du
monde sont des relais sportif qui
représente la france
les soutiennent les applaudissent les
critiques les siffler ou alors les
admire derrière lorsqu'ils prennent leur
retraite ils sont totalement abandonnés
donc je pense que ce niveau là il faut
vraiment à la fois changer la culture et
soutenir des gens qu'on admire et alors
il y en a qui sont très très bien payé
pour qui on va pas se
poser de questions pour l'avenir il y en
a d'autres qui sont abandonnés c'était
le cas notamment de emilie andéol qui a
été sacrée championne olympique de judo
jeux olympiques de rio en 2016 et trois
ans après elle s'est retrouvée au
chômage elle a d'ailleurs déclaré je
cite c'était difficile de l'avouer de se
dire que j'ai charbonné pendant douze
années pour en arriver là je me suis
battu personne ne croyait en moi j'étais
la bonne personne à l'entraînement que
personne ne regardait j'ai gagné les
jeux je me suis dit je veux en profiter
et finalement rien a priori elle a
retrouvé du travail mais elle avait sa
pose une question sur la suite pour les
sportifs la médaille et après sans
droits c'est vrai qu'on pense toujours
que qu'un champion une championne
olympique est forcément bien entouré
mais aujourd'hui en en étant chef
d'entreprise de perf et je me rends
compte qu'en poussant un peu nos
champions ne sont pas si bien entouré
que ça et parfois n'ose pas demander
cette aide ça a été le cas pour pour
emilie qui aujourd'hui nous dit qu'elle
s'est sentie seule mais très très seule
et que toutes ces démarches elle les a
faits seuls donc aujourd'hui il ya aussi
de l'aide mais plus que de l'aide aussi
de l'aide psychologique pour ces
sportifs canton quand on raccroche les
crampons ou composent nos perche on a
besoin aussi de ce soutien et quelle
retraite pour elle plus tard quelle
retraite de mémoire elle veut travailler
dans l'événementiel donc je crois que
pour l'instant elle n'y est pas je crois
qu'elle a été recrutée par une fondation
la fondation ippon technologies qui
qu'ils aident aujourd'hui dans sa
reconversion des mémoires parce que
quand vous pourrez de retraite ça sera
sa retraite de cotisation en tant que
travailleuse cette retraite devrait être
voilà le fait qu'elle ait participé à
des jeux olympiques qu'elle était
championne olympique ne va absolument
pas lui apporter des points ou des
cotisations supplémentaires pour sa
retraite imprécisions le bien il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de régimes de régime
spécifique pour les sportifs que vous
soyez champions du monde champions
olympiques vous ayez des effets des
championnats du monde
que vous ayez arrêté l'école à 14 ans
pour pleinement vous consacré à votre
carrière sportive il n'y a aucun régime
particulier pour vous et c'est ce qu'on
pourrait pas également combiner un
contrat à côté certains footballeurs qui
jouent dans des clubs et qui seront
employées également par certaines
municipalités qui peuvent continuer du
coup tu me lis des points alors ça ça
existe les sportifs aujourd'hui à
différents types de contrats qu'on
appelle des ces ip ou des contrats
d'image ou autre mais encore une fois ça
concerne vraiment l'élite de l'élite qui
peut être accompagnés j'ai pas citer
noms d'entreprises mais il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui en france qui
soutiennent les sportifs de haut niveau
dans leur double projet qui leur
permettent d'intégrer d'intérêt des
entreprises et de et de se former pour
ceux qui souhaitent également commencé à
se former et à mettre un pied dans le
monde de l'entreprise
donc du coup il faut un double projet
pierre rondeau son double projet n'y a
pas de retraite pour les sportifs ce qui
est sûr c'est que la mesure où alors le
cl on est sur le cas de figure où n'y
aura pas de régime spécifique de ne
pouvoir partir à la retraite à 40 ans
aux 42 ans
en ayant justifié des performances
sportives une réussite sportive
particulière ce qui est sûr c'est que le
sportif la sportive doivent être aidés
pour l'après carrière
donc si on sait qu'ils arrêtent l'école
à 14 ans pour la plupart ou alors
poursuivre des études parfois peu
diplômante ou peu valorisant son marché
professionnel
il faut les accompagner il faut attendre
aignan un accompagnement scolaire
accompagnement psychologique à l'équipe
de l'alimentation les syndicats c'est
uniquement ça devrait être le rôle des
110 kg à des sportifs de le faire c'est
vrai que le rôle de l'insep serait drôle
de la fédé des fédérations je pense au
football par exemple où pendant très
longtemps le football on n'était pas en
avant la réussite scolaire pendant très
longtemps les centres de formation en
france je pense notamment à l'olympique
de marseille mais à d'autres et beaucoup
d'autres ne visez pas comme réussite
la réussite scolaire et on se retrouve
avec des aspirants footballeurs qui
n'avaient pas le baccalauréat et des 120
formations qui présentait des résultats
de 2 à 5 % au bac depuis 2015 le nfp le
syndicat des footballeurs français a
imposé et ils ont réussi à ce que
dorénavant la les centres de formation
des clubs professionnels garantisse à la
fois la performance scolaire et la
performance sportive et aujourd'hui des
clubs comme l'olympique de marseille
c'est 100 % au bac dont 80 % de mention
et ça ça a été ça a été un combat des
syndicats pour protéger et soutenir les
sportifs il faut que ça soit élargie à
toutes les fédérations que tous les sens
les cas que toutes les fédérations
assure la continuité je dirais
diplômante et scolaire sandra qu'est ce
que vous dites vous peut-être pour
rebondir sur sa les fédérations avance
mine de rien on ne voit peut-être pas
mais dans beaucoup de fédérations il
existe des responsables suivi socio co
qui sont là justement pour accompagner
et orienter les sportifs a trouvé l'or
l'or l'ordre le prochain travail qui
veulent faire une fois la carrière
arrêtez donc il ya des choses qui sont
faites je prends l'exemple mois de
l'athlétisme que je connais mieux il ya
une ligue qui est assez récente et qui a
été mis en place
cette ligue tu en as aidé aujourd'hui
elle a commencé peut-être par la d30
sportif aujourd'hui c'est une
soixantaine dont ils ont vraiment cette
volonté d'aider le sportif parce que
mine de rien si le sportif né pour être
performant faut se sentir en équilibre
et pourrait-on et qu'il y faut aussi
penser à 7 après carrière
donc je pense que la question commence à
toucher un plus grand nombre
quelle retraite pour les athlètes on
continue d'en parler juste après la
pause à la suite de l'autre match quelle
retraite pour les athlètes on continue
d'en parler avec sur ce plateau
sandro ribeiro homo tavarez vous êtes
présidente de perf et aux et ancien
perchiste professionnel est à vos côtés
l'économiste du sport et chroniqueur bfm
rmc pierre rondeau on peut se poser
cette question quelle solution
finalement pour accompagner les sportifs
en vue de leur retraite éléments de
réponse avec ce sujet signé clément
delcourt lorsqu'on évoque la réforme des
retraites certains n'ont que le mot
financement à la bouche mais il suffit
de se tourner vers les sportifs les
mieux payés pour peut-être trouvé une
partie de la solution prenons l'exemple
de la ligue 1 le championnat de football
français 531 joueurs professionnels
salaire moyen un million cent soixante
dix mille euros par an soit environ 6
121 millions d'euros de masse salariale
totale si la réforme des retraites du
gouvernement est appliquée les
prélèvements permettrait de récolter
seulement 10,5 millions d'euros au titre
des cotisations de l'assurance retraite
mais en rétablissant un taux moyen sur
l'ensemble des salaires supérieurs à 120
mille euros par an on passait alors à
173 me
des prélèvements récoltés soit si fo à
l'actuel système des danseurs de l'opéra
de paris évalué lui à 28,7 millions
d'euros et les danseurs de l'opéra de
paris qui ont obtenu un sursis jusqu'en
2022 se recrutaient en 2022 seront
alignés sur le régime général avec une
prise en compte de la pénibilité
là on voit des solutions peut-être
d'ordre politique
pourquoi les danseurs de l'opéra
pourquoi pas les autres sportifs de haut
niveau sont en règle basescu essaie de
faire comprendre certains sportifs
j'ai lu récemment c'était fourcade qui
disait j'ai l'impression d'être seul et
que personne montant sur cette question
de retraite mais les sportifs commencent
aussi à prendre conscience donc
notamment via le syndicat des sportifs
je sais qu'à une pétition qui a été
lancée pour vraiment faire entendre
cette voix et d'ironie aussi les
sportifs on est là faut faut tenir en
compte et on a besoin d'un régime
je pense que quand le collectif sera
vraiment plus grands on entendra en ans
mènera les voix des sportifs notamment l
approche des jeux parce que faudra
faudra faire quelque chose pierre
rondeau on comprend qu'il ya les stars
et puis il ya les autres
oui oui bien sûr et là oh moi ce qui me
dérange justement précision dans le
la distinction entre les stars et les
autres c'est qu'avec la réforme qui
devrait être votée à l'assemblée donc
nous parlait le taux de cotisation et
c'était ça a été dit dans le reportage
le taux de cotisation puisse voir ça
peut paraître très technique ce que je
vais ce que je vais y arriver alors on
va essayer bulgarie zemin en gros si
vous voulez puisque on suppose qu'on a
passé un régime universel
largo grandes phrases du gouvernement
c'est un euro cotisé en euros touchés
donc dès lors que vous cotisez vous
toucherez ce que vous avez cotisé ce qui
est tout à fait normal et moi je
j'abonde dans 102
devenir sadisme sauf que on va plafonner
le versement des retraites à 10000 euros
par mois c'est à dire que tout donc
120000 euros par an toutes les personnes
qui touche aujourd'hui plus de 120000
euros par an ne toucherons pas au delà
10000 euros cette retraite par
cotisation mais de vous un e même par
capitalisation financer la retraite
exemple pour un joueur de foot qui
gagnent des régions plein et mappy qui
gagne un million 1,1 million 8 2 par
mois
ils cotisent pour les 10000 euros par
mois et au delà 10000 euros il ne peut
cotiser plus pour cette retraite qui ne
touchera pas toute façon ce sera à lui
de financer sa propre retraite par
capitalisation
donc dans cette logique de plafonnement
des retraites
et comme on suppose que 1 euro cotisé à
noeux retouchée et bien le gouvernement
a décidé à ce que le taux de cotisation
retraite passe de 28 % pour les salaires
entre 0 et 10 mille euros par mois à 2,8
pour cent pour les salaires entre 10000
euros et plus l'infini c'est dire que
plus vous êtes riche
- vous allez cotisés alors oui la
réponse c'est à dire parce que vous ne
toucherez pas cette retraite
pourquoi vous devriez payer pour hugo ce
que vous n'aurez pas donc essayer faire
rentrer on en a on sait qu'en france le
système de financement des retraites
c'est par solidarité contrairement aux
états unis ou séparés va dire mais la sq
faire rentrer le système de capital est
ce que je vous pose cette question
pierre rondeau l'a donc le seuil des 2
10000 euros
est-ce que plus tard on un gouvernement
et qui viendra pourra dire le seuil oms
la belle n'a de 10000 angoisse à faire
entrer le loup dans la bergerie la boîte
de pandore est donc exactement à partir
allemands on a un acte l'idée même de la
retraite par capitalisation
libre à ce que des reins gouvernement en
2022 2025 2030 de 10
on passe d'un plafond de 10000 euros à
8000 euros ces minéraux 5000 euros par
rapport aux sportifs et le reportage l'a
très bien expliqué à l'heure actuelle on
suppose que les danseurs de l'opéra de
paris londres on avait misé un régime
spécifique mais qu'on ne peut pas le
l'élargir à tous les sportifs par le
coup qu'on parle de 28 millions d'euros
pour le régime spécifique des danseurs
étoiles et des danseuses étoiles à au
moins 600 millions d'euros pour
l'ensemble des sportifs de haut niveau
un plus de 3000 sportifs de haut niveau
donc le coût est important
oui mais il ya de l'argent je veux dire
les footballeurs les neymar les amap et
les tous les grands joueurs un camp par
le 1 million 14000 euros par an de
salaire moyen en ligue 1 il ya beaucoup
d'argent et donc pourquoi ne pas il ne
paye même pas le petit colonisation
exactement il y aura pas de principes de
solidarité vers un fonds qui pourrait
abonder justement le régime spécifique
il y aura pas ce principe de solidarité
parce que l'idée d'un régime universel
un euro cotisé à nos routes ou chez ses
jolies dents discours mais c'est s'est
profondément individualiste c'est je
cotise un euro je touche 1 euro mais je
ne participe pas à la solidarité de tous
les sportifs
est ce que ça vous chaque sandra vous
qui avait représenté le portugal pour
les jeux olympiques mais vous êtes
également franco-portugaise ce que est
ce que ça vous choque ça de représenter
un pays de sentir que finalement notre
retraite allait pas cotiser par d'autres
sportifs qui représente le même pays et
qui vont finalement gagner plus non ce
qui est ce qui peut être choquant c'est
dire qu'on sacrifie en tant que sportif
de haut niveau
10 15 années de notre vie qui en fait au
final quand on s'arrête on n'a rien et
du coup c'est plus on représente comme
l'a si bien dit mon collègue en un
moment donné on est dans la lumière mais
quand on s'arrête
y'a plus personne n'y a rien et puis le
draw la crise elle et elle est double et
triple parce que ça va être une crise
financière parce qu'on n'a pas pu
cotiser donc demain faut faut rebondir
là dessus et trouver un emploi ça va
être une crise identitaire parce que on
sait plus qui en est on a été champions
et aujourd'hui il faut faut retrouver sa
place entre guillemets dans la société
ça va être une crise aussi physique
parce que sportif de haut niveau et l'a
été mais demain quand on arrête toutes
ses heures d'entraînement de musculation
bayal corps qui change et donc c'est
toute cette acceptation qu'il faut entre
guillemets faire comprendre aux systèmes
de nous aider parce que parce
qu'aujourd'hui bas
certes on est fort ronald mental quand
on est sur le terrain mais quand on
quand tout s'arrête et bah c'est là où
on a besoin d'être donc oui on a besoin
d'être aidée financièrement on a besoin
d'être aidé psychologiquement et la
question elle est bien plus importante
on s'arrête pas que sur le côté retraite
il ya beaucoup de points à traiter pour
aider les champions
je me permet de demeurer arrêté de
nouveau sur le point retraite avec les
sportifs qui viennent en france par
exemple neymar pour une durée supérieure
à 6 ans et qui vont vers les voilà
cotisé avec leur employeur au moins
vingt mille euros par an de cotisations
sociales et bien ils seront exonérés
deux versements à la caisse des
retraites il n'y a pas une forme
d'injustice l'a peut-être que c'est
moins gênant pour pour ces leaders qui
gagnent des sommes faramineuses et
peut-être que c'est que c'est là où on
peut trouver une solution parce qu'à un
moment donné faut bien que l'argent du
sport repartent entre guillemets aux
sportifs et donc c'est peut-être cette
solidarité qu'il faut retrouver mais
dans différents différents points
peut-être aller prendre de l'argent là
où il ya vraiment et puis le
redistribuer l'argent pour cela agira
plein de choses bien sûr effectivement
le sport doit financer le sport au-delà
du cas neymar et du régime des impatriés
il ya aussi par exemple la taxe buffet
qui est censée financer d' agences de
lagence national du sport via les droits
tv des sports professionnels et
notamment du football taxe buffet qui
est plafonné à 40 millions d'euros
donc en 2020 en juillet 2020 les droits
télé du foot français vont passer à 1
milliard 172 millions d'euros
eh bien le gouvernement a refusé le
déplacement la taxe pour qui aurait pu à
venir abonder le fonds pour l' agence du
sport
pourquoi parce que la différence sera
prélevé directement dans le budget de
l'état et l'état préfère qu'il
s'accaparait l'argent du foot plutôt que
leur distribuer directement aux sportifs
donc oui effectivement
peut-être que ça va tomber dans un débat
politique mais effectivement on est en
droit de se poser la question si on met
en avant le coût le financement la
difficulté de le financer
en tout cas des finances et un régime
spécifique l'argent il y en a je reviens
pour le cas du régime des impatriés et
de régie et le fait que neymar par
exemple ne paye pas on soit exonéré d'un
certain montant d'impôt sur le revenu et
de cotisations de retraite et santé et
chômage le débat sur la fiscalité c'est
le débat sur la compétitivité
certains on pourrait dire que neymar est
venue en france aussi grâce à ce régime
que si on avait maintenu un régime de
cotisation très élevé peut-être que des
joueurs de football des sportifs de haut
niveau étrangers ne seraient jamais
venus en france
donc certains disent que le fait de
proposer ces exonérations permet
d'attirer plus de jeu
on est en droit de se poser cette
question d'un autre côté on peut tout à
fait imaginer que l'argent qui permet de
financer aujourd'hui un joueur comme
neymar n'est pas de l'argent qui cherche
à être jours à être investis pour
générer une source de rentabilité
particulière c'est l'argent qui est
dépensé je dirais pour d'autres raisons
que qu'économique
donc si neymar aurait dû être payées 5 6
7 je suis millions d'euros via un
montant de cotisations plus élevées
il serait quand même venu donc le sport
aurait pu récupérer l'argent donc oui
voilà pour répondre à votre question il
y a de l'argent donc on peut financer
les régimes pour le sportif de haut
niveau c'est un choix politique
on continue de parler un petit peu du du
football même si vous cessez de
l'athlétisme sont à ribeiro avec avec
des stats intéressantes qui ont été
sortis par l' unfpa l'union nationale
des footballeurs professionnels en 2017
50% des footballeurs se retrouver ruinés
cinq ans après la fin de leur carrière
le salaire moyen c'est 46000 euros par
mois la durée de vie de moyenne en ligue
1 de quatre ans donc si on fait le
calcul ça fait un peu plus de deux
millions deux cent mille euros
voilà on se rend compte qu'il ya
finalement une logique à deux vitesses
maintenant avec également 25% des
footballeur qui a des liens qui touchait
les seuls 75 % des revenus totaux
je pense que ces chiffres pourraient
tout à fait être appelée type pour notre
sport et notamment le fait de les uns
sur deux qui roule ine cinq ans après sa
caresse à sa retraite sportive
j'imagine qu'en athlétisme wire c'est
oui je pense que ça s'applique à 2 à de
nombreux sports et que et que encore une
fois c'est c'est comment on nous éduquer
ce qu'on nous apprend qu est ce qu on
nous indique que pour qu'un moment donné
on puisse se préparer à cette fameuse
retraite à cette preuve fameuse
reconversion ou ce que vous dit qu'est
ce que vous dites vous à vos clients je
leur dis qu'il faut anticiper
aujourd'hui vraiment le maître mot c'est
anticipons anticipons ensemble anticipé
tant que vous êtes dans la lumière parce
qu'après ça sera plus difficile
d'anticiper et surtout en fait tu
prenais conscience
prenez conscience des choses parce
qu'aujourd'hui le sportif délègue
beaucoup il délègue ses affaires il
délègue pas mal de choses donc l'idée de
perf est au c vraiment de sensibiliser
mais aussi lui dire apprend apprend à
découvrir certaines choses parce que
demain quand tu seras plus sportif
c'est toi qui devra le faire tu devras
tu devras allait déclarer des revenus
tu dois le faire aujourd'hui donc
apprend à le faire et puis demain qui se
sentira beaucoup plus à l'aise et entre
guillemets c'est apprendre devenir
entrepreneur de ta carrière et si je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on devrait pour moi ça fait partie du
métier de sportif de haut niveau
chose que nous apprend pas aujourd'hui
mais qu'on devrait faire
systématiquement aller plus loin dans
cette démarche on ne s'arrête pas
uniquement à la formation on va bien au
delà de la formation gérer son image
savoir parler en public on le fait mais
pas suffisamment dernière question
pour trouver la solution à ce qu'il faut
pas aller au delà des frontières pour
essayer de trouver une solution qu'est
ce qui est fait dans les autres pays
dans votre dans votre rapport j'ai lu
que d'autres pays qui sont issus de l'ex
bloc soviétique russie pologne
biélorussie il ya un soutien social à
via un versement mensuel d'une somme
d'argent au profit du sportif retraités
pour mérite particulier exact en fait
pour d'or pour la rédaction la note je
me suis je m'étais demandé si au delà du
cas franco-français des pays appliquer
ou avait à voter des régimes
particuliers spécifique pour les
sportifs de haut niveau et les soutenait
tout au long de leur carrière et après
leur carrière et je me suis rendu compte
que des seuls pays qui avaient adopté ce
genre de régime particulier était comme
vous l'avez dit les anciens pays du bloc
soviétique russie pologne biélorussie
qui soutiennent véritablement leurs
sportifs de haut niveau qui partent du
principe alors j'ai pas faire de
l'apologie de ces pays mais qui partent
du principe que dans la mesure où on a
admiré ces sportifs et qu'ils ont
représenté le pays dans des compétitions
internationales
on doit leur vraiment les remercier pour
services rendus à la nation
donc on va continuer tout au long de
leur vie de les aider des sous terre via
des pensions de reversement des pensions
de soutien via des aides financières
parce qu'ils ont représenté de pays à
travers le monde
c'est le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
sandra ribeiro omar est d'avoir répondu
à nos questions également à à pierre
rondeau évidemment vous pouvez revivre
cette émission l'autre au match en
replay ou en podcast sur rt france point
tv et quant à nous on se donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'autre match et bah
est resté sur arte france
[Musique]